- What's up, y'all?
(audience applauding)
I'm back with Jessie Ennis, give it up!
I love your dress, by the way,
and I want it.
- [Jessie] Thank you!
- I hope my stylist is
looking at you right now.
Getting in trouble with
the law at an early age
can lead to a lifetime
of consequences for kids.
My next guest is looking to
change all that in Seattle
with an innovative program
that gives kids an alternative.
Instead of being prosecuted,
they can choose to see the
best in themselves and thrive.
Take a look.
(air whooshes)
- CHOOSE 180 as a nonprofit organization.
Our foremost goal is to
transform systems of injustice
to no longer do harm to communities,
particularly, the black
and brown community.
- So tell me about a time
that you made that different decision.
- [Sean] The difference
between a young person
who's successful,
and a young person who has challenges,
has everything to do with the
community surrounding them.
(slapping sound)
- What the program aims to do is
to not label a kid for a mistake.
It seeks to help the kid
make better decisions.
It doesn't always have to be a jail cell,
or a judge, or a courtroom.
- Last year, we supported
a little over 500 youth
and young adults.
Over 90% of them don't return
to the criminal legal system
within 12 months of
participating in our program.
Which means that community is better
because a young person is better,
because that family is better.
(audience applauds)
(air whooshes)
- This is the greatest organization.
I'm so excited y'all.
Over the years, Sean Goode,
the executive director
of CHOOSE 180 has helped
more than 6,000 kids
turn their lives around.
He's what we like to call a "Rad Human."
(lively music)
- Woo!
(Kelly applauds)
Please welcome Sean, everybody!
What's up, man?
How you doing?
- I am amazing, Kelly.
- Well, meet Jessie.
- Hi, nice to meet you.
- Hey Jessie.
- [Jessie] Hi.
- Great to meet you as well.
- [Jessie] You too.
- Well we were just talking in the break,
how excited we are, like,
she does this podcast.
She gets to meet people
that are really cool
and changing people's lives
and have a lot of information
that we, maybe, don't know about.
And I have been so excited
since reading all about you,
about having you on the show.
I think it's incredible what you're doing.
So, two very different
events in your childhood
inspired what you do right now, right?
- Yeah, absolutely.
You know, when I was six years old,
I visited my brother,
who, at the age of 13,
was incarcerated for a
poor choice that he made
and he was locked up inside of a kid jail
until he was a 21-year-old man.
And when I went to visit him on this day,
the security guard, when I
stepped into the building,
pointed me to an article that
was on the wall behind me.
And this article was all about my brother
and how he did this amazing job going
and visiting a school and
inspiring the young people.
And it wasn't lost on me at the age of six
that, although he could do so much great
outside of this building,
because of a poor choice he
made when he was a 13-year-old,
he was stuck in here until he was 21.
And by the time I got to
the age of about 10, 11, 12,
I had a really difficult
anger management problems.
And I would break holes
and doors and walls
and even harm my mother and
the police got called on me.
And I remember this day clearly,
when the police brought me down
and put me in the back
of their car and said,
"Look, we can take you with
us or send you back upstairs.
But if we send you back upstairs,
and we have to come back,
you're definitely coming with us again."
And that moment of grace was
a big pivot moment for me
that helped me commit to a
new direction for my life.
- Wow!
And that's quite a moment
too, because you never know
you know, what the kid
will choose, you know,
and it's an interesting thing though,
that you've pointed out,
that they can choose the positive path.
And I think that's the coolest
part of what you're doing.
The kids in CHOOSE 180, just have to do
a one-day program to get
their charges dropped, right?
So how does it work?
- We have this really unique relationship
with the district
attorneys in our community
where we're able to give
young people community
instead of a courtroom.
And, essentially, what happens
is when a young person's
behavior is criminalized, they
get referred to our program
instead of referred to the court system.
They show up to the
shared space with people
with lived experience that mirrors them.
They hear testimonies from
folks through this exercise
we have called the
"Color of Connectedness,"
where, I'll tell my story, for example,
about how I used to damage
property that wasn't mine.
And then, I will invite the young people,
they're connected adults,
the prosecutors in the space,
the staff, the volunteers.
So I'll come down and get
like a green Mardi Gras bead
and we'll do the same thing
for physical violence,
for theft, and drugs, and alcohol.
And before you know it,
everybody in the space
has these beads around their neck
and the young people recognize
that I'm not here because I'm guilty,
'cause if that's the case,
then all of us are guilty.
Then it must be for something different.
It's for grace.
And we've recognized that
grace is a far better motivator
for behavior change than
guilt ever could be.
- Absolutely.
Did you feel like you
had moments in your life
that you're like, "Oh, God,
I'm glad that my whole path
wasn't decided because
of that one thing, like,
one mistake."
- Yeah, yeah, I mean, what you're saying,
it really reminds me of this
thing that I try to recognize,
which is that, like,
there's angels everywhere.
And so, my story is
when I was a little kid,
I didn't really like school that much,
but I knew I wanted to be an actor.
And my parents sent me
to this acting program
over the summer.
And then the following semester,
we hadn't enrolled because
my family was tight on money
and we just couldn't afford to swing it.
And the director of the
program called my parents
and be like, "Hey, we noticed
that Jessie isn't signed up
for this next semester.
Just trying to, you know,
make sure that you're all good to go.
Like it's starting soon."
And my mom explained, "Oh, you know,
we're a little tight right now.
So we're gonna take a little time off.
And this director of
the program, she said,
"Well, you know, Jessie
is really intense in class
and she gets the other kids to focus.
So, we wanna offer her
a lifetime scholarship
and she can come whenever she wants."
And so, I got to go to
acting classes for 10 years
because of this woman Ellen Mendel.
And it was like-
- [Kelly] Wow!
- totally blessed by an
angel kind of moment.
I'm so grateful to her.
- You know, it's so funny.
I had similar moments in my life.
We had no money.
There wasn't a lot of support in that area
'cause there just couldn't be.
And I had people help me.
And I think what you're saying is,
if you give kids that maybe
don't have the opportunity,
because of finances they
don't have, the opportunity,
because of, they don't
have support system,
those little moments, look
at where we are right now.
We would probably not be here
had people not believed in us
and had they not, you know,
kind of helped us on a better path,
and one that we'd had opportunity.
A few years ago, our
next guest was homeless
and facing serious jail time.
That's when she discovered CHOOSE 180
and made a commitment to change.
Now, her life looks drastically different.
Everybody, say hello to Lamaria!
(audience applauds)
Hi, Lamaria!
- Hi!
- Hi, say hi to Jessie, as well.
- Hi, Jessie!
(Kelly giggles)
- All right, well, Lamaria,
can you tell us a little
about your background first?
- You know, I grew up and
I was bullied, you know,
being a bigger girl,
my mom wasn't financially stable to get me
the things that could distract
bullies from bullying me.
So, at about 13, my behavior
changed and I began stealing.
I didn't enter the criminal justice system
until I was 18, for theft.
And, when I went to jail, I got out,
I got out to being homeless, Kelly.
I got out to couch surfing, you know,
and I was entering into survival mode.
"How can I survive?"
And that led to cashing bad checks
and cashing bad checks led to
facing seven felony forgeries.
So, you can only imagine,
you know, how that was.
- I think that's the interesting
thing about situations
like this, is everybody
thinks they're invincible.
You're not, you don't have any idea, like,
what could happen, your
place could burn down.
Everything can go up in flames.
And, all of a sudden,
you're in a completely
different environment,
or you don't have the support around you.
You don't have people to call for money,
and, like, not everybody has that.
And that can happen to anyone.
Well, what was your experience
like with the program?
- Oh, my experience was amazing, Kelly.
You know, like I said
earlier, I was homeless.
I was in a place where I didn't know
if I could stop stealing.
I didn't know if I could
stop cashing checks.
And, I came into the program,
I walked into the workshop,
thinking it's going to be a one day thing,
but it turned into two years and a half
of turning my life around,
building amazing relationships.
And I, in that, in the midst
of that time, I got stable.
I learned life lessons.
How to financially save, how
to be stable within a home.
They paid for all my moving costs.
Just, just a new start for me.
It was amazing, honestly, truthfully,
and in the midst of that as well,
all seven forgery
charges, Kelly, are gone.
(Lamaria laughs)
(audience applauds)
I did not have to go to jail.
There were so many community
leaders that, on my behalf,
wrote a letter that, you know,
"Lamaria, you know, was in
a circumstances to survive
and that's not her.
She can do better."
And that resulted to employment.
Sean just offered me
employment to give back
to my community, to help out youth,
young girls just like me.
So, that's my calling.
And I just wanna be the best at that.
- I love it.
You wanna be the best version of yourself.
And that's what I love from the video too,
that we played before we brought Sean out,
is, you know, he said, "This
isn't just a good thing
for these individuals.
It's an amazing thing
But it's an even bigger thing
and in a bigger impact on
the community as a whole."
Lamaria, I understand
that you have something
you wanna say to Sean, right?
- Yes, I do.
Uncle Sean, I just wanted to let you know,
thank you for everything
you've done for me.
Thank you for everything you
do for the Seattle community.
I love you forever for it.
And I appreciate all the opportunities
and I can't wait to see
what the future holds.
(audience applauds)
- And we love what CHOOSE 180 is all about
and how it's changing lives.
So, Sean, we are giving
the program $10,000.
How's that sound?
- What?!
Oh, that sounds amazing, Kelly!
(Kelly laughs and applauds)
- All right!
We love what you're doing
and I've been so excited, literally,
to have you on this show.
And I'm, I'm, it's just such a gift.
You're such a gift
and you should let those tears flow, man.
That means it matters, it's okay.